اردوغان وكيليجار اوغلو لا يجمعهما سوى
الاختلاف حتى على صعيد السياسه الخارجيه
ففي ظل حكم اردوغان كانت العلاقه التركيه
بالغرب متذبذبه حليفه
وكان شراء انقره لمنظومه اس 4 الروسيه سبب
فرض عقوبه امريكيه عليها
اما في حال فوزك الجدار اوغلو فيعد بانه
سيصلح العلاقه مع الغرب وتكون السياسه
الخارجيه اقل شخصيه واكثر دبلوماسيه
عرقله لانضمام السويد وفنلندا لحلف النيتو
كان سببها اردوغان اما كليجدار اوغلو
فيتسم بهدوء اكبر باتجاه الاوروبيين
ساستانف طلب تركيا بالانضمام للاتحاد
الاوروبي واحرصوا على الامتثال لاحكام
محكمه حقوق الانسان
[تصفيق]
تدخل تركي جلي في دول الجوار بدا من خلال
العمليات العسكريه في كل من العراق وسوريا
الا ان كيليجار اوغلو اكد انه سيتبنى
سياسه عدم التدخل دون الافصاح عن انسحاب
عسكري
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات